nos sociétés modernes pose de grands
problèmes environnementaux qui est
devenu urgent de résoudre
face à cette urgence environnementale il
semble indispensable de développer les
meilleurs outils imaginables pour
relever ces défis aussi bien que
possible et les outils de collecte de
données d'analysé de données et des
dallas décisions auront sans doute un
rôle central à jouer
et pour bien vous en parler j'ai invité
rodolphe de la chaîne le réveil heures
dis-moi rodolphe quels sont aujourd'hui
les secteur économique qui engendre le
plus d'impacts environnementaux et que
peuvent faire lire pour réduire leur
impact environnemental
salut les c'est sympa de m'inviter sur
la chaîne et bonjour à tous
il s'agit en fait d'une très vaste
question donc pour aujourd'hui je te
propose de nous arrêter sur deux des
secteurs les plus importants le
transport et l'agriculture
ça marche commençons par le transport
pas besoin de vous faire un dessin une
voiture camion un bateau ou un avion qui
se déplacent ça qu'on sorte de l'énergie
fossile et sa rejette du co2 beaucoup de
co2 du coup pour diluer notre impact
environnemental
il est important de minimiser les
transports typiquement une partie de ce
transport correspond à la livraison de
colis par camion chacun de ces colis a
une origine une destination il s'agit
d'affecter les colis au bon camion et
d'optimiser la route que suivront les
différents camions pour livrer les colis
et revenir au dépôt
or ça ça correspond justement un
problème classique d'optimisation appelé
le problème de tourner deux véhicules
qui étaient un peu la spécialité du
groupe de recherche où j'effectue ma
thèse et dès qu'on utilise des systèmes
d'information centralisé ou parvient
assez vite à diviser par deux les
consommations de carburant par rapport
au cas où les tracés sont choisis par
des humains un autre problème est le
taux de remplissage des camions l'aller
et faciles à commercialiser et on
remplit bien le camion mais s'il fait le
retour à vide il aura un taux de
remplissage de moins de 50 % et aura
généré les impacts environnementaux pour
rien plus le taux de remplissage est
élevé plus l'activité de ce camion est
financièrement et écologiquement
rentable et sur cet aspect les outils
qui sont arrivés avec les technologies
de l'information ont permis de réduire
les transports à vis de 43 % appliqué il
ya assez secteur permettrait
probablement d optimisation de plus en
plus performantes de la même façon des
technologies comme le gps et l'analyse
du trafic en temps réel sur google maps
ou waze permettent de fluidifier le
trafic et de réduire un peu la
consommation énergétique et ce n'est
qu'un début
isbergues aux états unis ni à ger 50
intersections et ajuste les feux
tricolores en fonction du trafic
elle a déjà permis de réduire le temps
de trajet de 25 % les émissions de 20%
eh oui ne pas avoir à s'arrêter à
redémarrer est un gain de carburant
intéressant en plus d'être plaisant cet
exemple suggère d'ailleurs aussi que le
déploiement à large échelle de véhicules
autonomes pourraient aussi avoir un
impact important sur la consommation de
carburant
à condition bien sûr que les capteurs il
ya qui gérera tout ça ne soit pas trop
gourmands en énergie et en matériaux ces
véhicules autonomes pourraient aussi
permettre de fabriquer moins de
véhicules et diminue la place qu'ils
occupent dans nos villes ainsi depuis
avril 2017 les web os et voitures
autonomes de google sont en mode taxi
sans conducteur pour 400 utilisateurs à
phoenix dans l'arizona et en mai
2010huit wimo a annoncé qu'il serait
accessible à tout habitant de phoenix il
y as pourrait donc révolutionner le
transport urbain dans un avenir pas si
lointain
ceci dit si on cherchait vraiment à
moins consommer de carburant et à moins
polluer
surtout si vous êtes en ville il y à
déjà l'option des transports en commun
de la marche et du vélo
de même dans le cas du fret il existe
des alternatives moins polluante que le
camion comme le fret ferroviaire
enfin il ya une autre façon plus
radicale encore et plus efficace de
consommer moins de carburant il suffit
en effet de moins se déplacer et sa
grâce aux technologies de l'information
c'est souvent possible par exemple via
le télétravail il sera peut être temps
de remettre en question les allers
retours en avion pour une réunion de
quelques heures ou pour un colloque un
autre secteur d'activité qui provoque de
nombreux problèmes environnementaux et
l'agriculture l'exploitation agricole
affecte la qualité des sols de l'eau de
l'air la biodiversité et la santé
humaine
par exemple la culture pose des
problèmes 2 trophies à sion qui sont dus
à l'utilisation excessive d'azoté et de
phosphore et qui conduisent à des
bouleversement des équilibres
écologiques comme l'agriculture et le
lieu où il ya le plus d'interactions
entre l'environnement et les sociétés
humaines
il n'est pas étonnant de retrouver ce
secteur économique au milieu de beaucoup
des enjeux environnementaux
en fait d'après le rapport de villani il
y a urgence pour ce secteur à se saisir
des opportunités de l'intelligence
artificielle
oui parce que ce dont on ne se rend pas
forcément compte c'est que gérer une
production agricole est un problème
d'une très grande complexité avec un
grand nombre de variables sur lesquels
on peut jouer il faut ainsi choisir
quelle graine plantée dans quel sol à
quel moment qu'elle engrais et quels
pesticides
utiliser et quelle quantité d'eau
utilisée et à quel moment sauf que les
réponses à toutes ces questions
dépendent de nombreuses données tout
aussi complexes comme les propriétés des
graines la qualité des sols les maladies
qui attaquent les plantes et les
conditions climatiques et
météorologiques sans ia et sans donner
on a ainsi tendance à prendre des
décisions sous optimal et à utiliser les
engrais les pesticides et l'eau en
grande quantité plusieurs entreprises
dont microsoft cherche donc à proposer
des outils de collecte de données et des
capteurs des caméras ou même des images
satellites afin de mieux connaître les
conditions environnementales de
l'agriculture à un lieu donné et de
mieux ajuster les besoins en engrais ou
autres voire de cibler les parties du
champ qui ont vraiment besoin d'intrants
mieux ajuster les besoins en engrais et
en pesticides et en os pourrait
grandement diminuer l'utilisation de ces
produits tout en conservant voir en
augmentant la production agricole en
indonésie mme thuillier a permis aux
agriculteurs d'augmenter de 30% la
production d'arachide par hectare on
parle d'agriculture de précision puisque
on cherche alors être plus précis dans
la manière d'exploiter les terres
agricoles
l'ia est aussi capable de surveiller les
terres en temps réel en assimilant de
grandes quantités de données y compris
des images satellites que des humains
n'ont pas forcément envie de regarder
toute la journée
l'ia peut donc aider à détecter et à
réagir rapidement à des incendies et une
telle activité de surveillance ne se
limite d'ailleurs pas à l'agriculture
l'iap surveiller de vastes zones étaient
étaient des activités de pêche de
braconnage d'exploitation forestière
illégale un suivi plus précis de
différents problèmes et environnementaux
comme l'eutrophisation ou la création de
zones mortes ou la prolifération
d'espèces invasives peut
considérablement aider la mise en place
d'actions de lutte contre ces problèmes
il ya ne le résoudra à ses problèmes par
magie mais elle peut fournir des
informations détaillées et fiables pour
mieux lutter contre
enfin il ya peu accélérer la recherche
en agronomie par exemple cette industrie
investit aujourd'hui 2,6 milliards de
dollars par an dans la recherche de
meilleurs produits agrochimiques
l'étude de modèles complexes pourrait
permettre d'accélérer la recherche de
nouvelles molécules
il ya pourrait également permettre de
mieux anticiper les performances de
différentes graines et ainsi d'optimiser
le processus de sélection de ces graines
on a donc parlé du transport et de
l'agriculture mais il ya bien d'autres
domaines où il ya peut permettre de
mieux gérer notre impact environnemental
de façon générale quand il s'agit de
surveiller des systèmes complexes dont
on
mesurée de nombreuses caractéristiques
en continu il y à a le potentiel d'aidé
par exemple la pollution de l'air est un
des problèmes environnementaux majeurs
en france et d'april oms c'est la
troisième cause de mortalité est
derrière le tabac et l'alcool et la
france est loin d'être le pire
en considérant la pollution de l'air
intérieur et extérieur le ms estime le
nombre de morts à 7 millions dans le
monde
un début et plus touchés par cette
problématique et bien entendu la chine
et ses lacs ibm et utilise une nouvelle
ia pour mieux prévoir les pics pollution
et identifier les sources de ces
polluants tati a fait déjà mieux que les
modèles existants grâce aux données déjà
disponibles comme l'activité
industrielle les estimations de trafic
et les conditions météorologiques avec
ses connaissances on peut prévenir les
populations pour qu'elles se protègent
mais on peut aussi agir sur les causes
en coupant momentanément des usines ou
en limitant le trafic routier
une fois les causes identifiées les
pouvoirs publics peuvent également lancé
des actions sur du plus long terme et
déployaient des transports ou des
industries plus durable d'autres
intelligences artificielles peuvent
aider les villes à mieux gérer leur
trafic et leur flux d'énergie et de
matière on parle parfois de smart cities
j'avais été par exemple pas mal étonné
dans ma vidéo sur les ressources en eau
d'apprendre l'importance des fuites dans
la consommation d'eau et bien c'est
aussi un endroit où liam peut donner un
coup de main en détectant les fuites
souterraines dans le réseau de
distribution
si on met les bons capteurs en place
elle pourrait en profiter pour suivre la
qualité de l'eau et prévenir en cas de
problème
l'ia peut aussi aider considérablement
la recherche en particulier quand il
s'agit de modélisation complexe qui
repose sur des quantités de données
énormes
en particulier elle pourrait améliorer
les prédictions des modèles de
changement climatique
bien sûr on pourrait rétorquer que ça
n'est pas forcément on sait ce qui cause
le changement climatique en grande
partie le co2 et on sait ce qu'il faut
faire arrêter dans mes maîtres mais il
faut se rendre compte que le changement
climatique est déjà en cours il a et
aura des impacts lee hae le diplôme
permet de mieux comprendre comment le
climat peut changer à l'échelle locale
et donc de mieux s'adapter à ces
changements
on va subir des effets du changement
climatique et il faudra faire avec
tout est là l'adaptation est donc
bienvenu une des conséquences attendues
du changement climatique et par exemple
l'augmentation des vagues de chaleur qui
sont particulièrement dévastatrice dans
les environnements bétonné que sont les
villes une autre a dit bm exploite
d'autres stratégies pour lutter contre
ça et optimise par exemple le couvert
végétal des vies
pour limiter l'impact des vagues de
chaleur pour lutter contre ce fléau
sanitaire qui va s'aggraver dans les
années à venir
il ya peu vous aider à mettre en place
les actions les plus adaptées
on a tendance
opposés technologies environnement comme
si la technologie et l'industrialisation
était nécessairement néfaste à la nature
et oui en effet clairement beaucoup de
nos technologies engendre de graves
problèmes environnementaux
mais toutes les technologies n'ont pas
cette vocation en particulier de nos
joueurs de plus en plus de chercheurs
d'associations et d'entreprises
cherchent au contraire à exploiter au
mieux les technologies modernes pour
réduire autant que possible notre impact
écologique et il y a urgence en terme
environnemental
le statu quo est catastrophique et il
faut donc absolument améliorer nos
façons de faire et lie à ajustement le
potentiel de grandement nous aider à
effectuer cette transition vers des
sociétés plus durable
melia ne suffira certainement pas il y a
urgence a également modifié nos
habitudes pour préparer la raréfaction
du pétrole protéger la biodiversité et
éviter un changement climatique brutal
et évidemment l'existence d'application
de l'ia bénéfique pour l'environnement
n'implique pas que toutes les
applications de l'ia sont louables
surtout qu'il ne faut pas oublier que
lee a elle même est très consommatrice
d'énergie et il y aurait d'ailleurs
beaucoup à dire sur les impacts de l'ia
sur l'industrie de l'énergie et du coup
les sept dirait de venir en parler sur
machine allait gauche et réveillère un
énorme merci à rodolphe de la chaîne le
rêveur pour avoir participé à cette
vidéo qui me fait énormément suez parce
que c'est un sujet qui est réellement de
mon champ des expertises et c'est pas
l'habitude de traiter des sujets aussi
complexes sur ma chaîne et j'ai vraiment
vraiment beaucoup galéré à préparer ces
épisodes vu énormément lire m'informer
j'ai appris énormément de choses et
c'était extrêmement indispensable en
fait d'avoir quelqu'un pour mieux guider
dans ses réflexions autour des
applications de liens en terme
environnemental
donc comme je le disais dans vidéo
précédente avec rim sommes appliqués
liés à ce genre de domaine requiert faut
des expertises en venir mais également
des expertises dans le domaine en
question ici dans le domaine
environnemental parce que beaucoup de
choses en devenant le mental sont
incroyablement plus subtil et plus
compliqué que ce qu'on pourrait croire
de prime abord est globalement on est
très très très très ignorants quand il
s'agit d'étudier des systèmes complexes
comme ceux de l'écologie pour vous en
convaincre je vous invite très très très
très vivement à aller voir les vidéos de
rodolphe sur la chaîne
au réveil heures par exemple vous pouvez
voir sa vidéo sur les pic pétrolier pour
vous rendre compte qu'en fait c'est
vraiment d'un problème qui est
extrêmement préoccupant et qui pourrait
être dans un avenir pas si lointain et
qui risquent de complètement bouleversé
nos façons de faire et nos modes de vie
actuels et bien sûr l'autre vidéo
d'eurveilher que je recommande c'est
celle à laquelle j'ai participé qui a
été publié en même temps que cette vidéo
sur les impacts énergétiques de liga qui
sont assez catastrophique mais qui ont
aussi des monts côté puisque il ya peut
permettre de mieux gérer nos
consommations énergétiques nos clients
notamment les smart grids
les verts font apparaître des
applications de l'ia en santé on n'avait
pas le permis notamment du problème de
responsabilité
si on y apprend une décision qui se
trouve être une vision pour un patient y
conduit à la mort du patient
est ce qu'il y aura quelqu'un qui est
responsable et si quelqu'un vous savez
ce qu'il s'agit du concepteur de l'ia
est ce qu'il s'agit de celui qui est la
mise en place celui qui est là acheter
celui qu'il a implémenté où le médecin
qui était en charge de choisir
l'utilisation de ces tirs portel
patients toutes ces questions se posent
mais pas tuée clac hui qu affirme que
finalement c'est peut-être pas si
important que de savoir comment
attribuer cette responsabilité après
tout la notion d'attribuer la
responsabilité d'un événement à
quelqu'un est une notion finalement
assez discutable ce qu'ils nous ont dit
qu'on avait d'ailleurs pas mal parlé
dans la série sur la démocratie
notamment dans l'épisode 25 surtout pas
ceux qui parlent d'une injustice sans
libre arbitre c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance nous humains à aimer
identifiait des responsables surtout
lorsqu'il ya des événements tragiques
pour pouvoir se plaindre notamment de
ces personnes c'est une attitude qui est
d'ailleurs assez récurrente sur twitter
on aime se plaindre d'avoir un
responsable de quelque chose qui va pas
et de se plaindre donc typiquement la
france a gagné du monde mais en
allemagne juste après que l'allemagne se
soit fait éliminer de la coupe du monde
pour le premier réflexe qui est
finalement assez courant de la première
intuition morale c'est de se dire mais
qu'est ce qui est responsable quelle est
la personne qui est responsable de
l'échec de l'équipe d'allemagne et puis
du coup on sort différent non et ça que
c'est une attitude assez générale que je
trouve pas forcément très saine que de
toujours vouloir qui identifiait des
responsables d'un éveil
alors que souvent il ya une certaine
diffusion de responsabilité qui
intervient à différents niveaux et le
système beaucoup plus complexe et
finalement j'aurais envie de dire non
moment on s'en fout des responsabilités
si on est vraiment conseillé concia
liste moral ce qui importe c'est avant
tout les conséquences des différentes
actions ont été entreprises en
particulier est ce que plus de patients
ont été sauvés que deux patients qui ont
été tués par l'utilisation d'une
intelligence artificielle en tout cas si
on est quitte à risque se rend à ça
compense ceci étant dit comme j'en ai
parlé aux parents de restriction
démocratie l'utilité première notamment
des responsabilités c'est d'essayer de
donner des incentives aux personnes qui
sont responsables de la que ceux qui
interviennent dans le fait dans le cours
des événements qui ont conduit à
potentiellement une tragédie ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est qu'elles sont
ces personnes qui étaient responsables
qui ont un terme qui sont intervenus et
surtout qu'est ce qu'elle aurait pu
faire pour que les choses aillent mieux
je pense que c'est vraiment plus comme
ça qu'il faut poser les questions en
tout cas c'est comme ça que j'ai déposée
dans cette vidéo se dresser sur
democracy la question intéressante c'est
peut-être qu'elles sont les incentives à
mettre en place et pour mettre de telles
initiatives en place il faut se rendre
compte que c'est un thème important
d'avoir une espèce de traçabilité pour
savoir quelles sont les différentes
personnes qui sont différents processus
qui sont intervenus qui ont conduit à
telle ou telle tragédie
et ça ça me permet de faire une
transition vers la question de blocs qui
se posent la question d'entendre de
l'utilisation de la broken pour pouvoir
avoir cette notamment cette traçabilité
donc la bonne chaîne pour ceux qui
connaissent pas je suis en train d'en
parler dans sur la chaîne youtube string
theory une série de vidéos notamment la
dernière parler des deux principes
fondamentaux d'albert king mais de façon
très grossière ne bloquions c'est avant
tout une base de données extrêmement
sécurisé et donc sur cette base de
données extrêmement sécurisé
chacun pourrait écrire et se serait
immuable il pourrait écrire que mon âge
et contribué à concevoir telle machine
que j'ai transmise à telle personne que
l'autre personne peut dire j'ai en effet
reçu la machine d'intel et je les
utilise et wau j'ai rajouté telle ou
telle fonctionnalité
donc il y aura vraiment une traçabilité
de toutes les étapes qui ont conduit à
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle pour telle ou telle
application
et ça ça peut être très utile pour
pouvoir notamment retrouver ce qui
aurait pu être amélioré et pour pouvoir
justement améliorer les ja
à venir ce que je pense que c'est
vraiment ça c'est dans une optique
conséquences et qu'on se dit que
l'objectif c'est vraiment de sauver un
maximum de patients si c'est vraiment ça
l'objectif c'est vraiment important de
savoir c'est toute traçabilité pour
savoir qu'est ce qui peut être être
améliorés notamment une fois qu'on a
observé quelque chose qui n'allait pas
et en cela sans doute que des
technologies comme la blokhine seront
très utiles
d'abord ce principe n'est pas du tout
spécifique à l'utilisation d'une
technologie comme il ya en santé il est
même assez générale à toutes les
technologies qu'on utilise en santé
notamment par exemple les médicaments et
je vous renvoie notamment vers la
présentation de telit le sac les deux
une cape et très qui a longuement parlé
les applications de la bloque shane en
santé et j'espère que vous avez aimé cet
épisode et que petit à petit c'est de
vous convaincre notamment que l'ia est
vraiment utile voire indispensable pour
pouvoir préparer le futur
et c'est encore une chose qu'on va voir
dans l'épisode 2 prochain où j'essayais
de défendre la thèse sur laquelle il ya
même indispensable à la survie de
l'humanité sur le long terme notamment à
cause de ce qu'on appelle lé risque
existentiel
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
le lac et à le commenter à le partager
quand ça vous avez répondu comme enquête
sur l'épisode vers ce petit beurre pour
leurs dons et j'espère que vous serez là
la prochaine fois en france les piles
sont jamais de l'hydroélectricité qui
est plutôt propre mais aussi avec du gaz
naturel qui n'est pas mal de co2 il y a
pour effet rmel d'effectuer ce qu'on
appelle des effacements c'est à dire vos
portes et l'activité de machines à 10
heures de faible consommation